[Music]
Rihanna behind the scenes with her bow
ASAP Rocky and their baby boy it's all
an exciting Journey so far I'm just
taking it as it comes the singer and her
fam are British vogue's March cover
stars and the mag dropped this Glimpse
inside her Malibu photo shoot featuring
the rapper and their nine-month-old son
[Music]
you enjoying about this journey with
three right now everything about it I'm
loving it there's also this sweet shot
of the little guy with riri's Mom Monica
first of all your mom never wants you to
grow up too fast and you just want to do
whatever she does and I have always just
admired her so much the couple welcomed
their son last May and REE made the big
reveal they're expecting baby number two
during her Super Bowl halftime show
[Applause]
when you become a mom there's something
that just happens where you feel like
you could take on the world you can do
anything and the Super Bowl is one of
the biggest stages in the world so
as scary as that was because I haven't
been on stage in seven years
there's something exhilarating about the
challenge of it all and it's important
for for me to do this this year it's
important for representation it's
important for
my son to see that in the Vogue
interview Rihanna said she's grateful to
have rocky by her side quote we're best
friends with a baby adding that having a
baby only made them closer I'm just
excited for what I don't know yet you
know everything is new to me so you know
I'm excited despite being new to
fatherhood rienna calls Rocky's bond
with their son undeniable I'm just
sitting on the sidelines when they're
together I'm literally the girl trying
to get into the boys club waiting for my
turn he is obsessed with his father and
I'm like didn't I give birth to you what
is going on you have an Oscar nomination
and the show how's this run been for you
and what does it mean to you you know it
really feels Like A lot's happening all
at once it feels like motherhood Oscar
Super Bowl yeah ree's tackling another
first at the Oscars along with earning
her first nomination for Lift Me Up her
song from Black Panther wakanda forever
she'll also be performing it at the show
March 12th
[Music]
I'm in love I need love I need love I'm
still pinching myself really I'm
grateful I'm grateful
[Music]
foreign